all right lucky
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I was born in Redwood
City California and I lived in East Palo
Alto which is up north
um so I was about 13.
tell me about your family growing up
um
uh
I have a younger brother and an older
sister and did not get along with either
of them most of our Lives me and my
brother are super tight now and we both
hate the older ones so that worked out
better in the end but um my stepdad was
super abusive to only me
and eventually me and my mom moved away
from me and my brother after my sister
went to college
how would you describe your childhood in
general
it was tactic
but I mean what ways
um I mean him he was a really abusive
alcoholic
but the only thing I like that I can say
good about my child is like my parents
did give me the best of everything like
we went to really good schools
I was a gymnast figure skater for like
14 years
they really gave a [__] about like
I guess what we would become
and that works out real well
your life took a turn though
yeah
when did the drugs start for you
I was about 11.
so you're doing like gymnastics and
skating while you were
not using WOW
who introduced you to that
oh my my best friend
she was a couple years older than me we
grew up in the same uh
condo complex in East Falwell too
I met her when I was like four or five
and um yeah she was a couple years older
than me so you know
Grunge music was still really big it was
still alive and everybody was doing
heroin so
that's what I started with
any other other addicts in your family
oh yeah my dad
he was he was a heroin user as well
do you graduate high school
no I was in prison by the time
but I think I went to Black Canyon when
was that um
the October of my freshman year October
my first one year of high school
I was already in prison
how many years do you do
then I did three
yeah I did three years for her and
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
what happened when you're finally free
um I actually got married and well got
pregnant got married
and got illegally got legally out for a
while that was kind of cool before my
18th birthdays that was for that that
was pretty dope
but yeah that didn't last either
the hell do you know I'm 39. 39. you've
been living on the streets for a while
yeah everything I was homeless in L.A
for the last let's see I got out of
prison in 2000
so since then I was homeless but I
recently just got my section 8.
so I'm finally on the streets anymore
how many children do you have three
did you raise them no
where are your kids
um my oldest is off on his own I I'm
guessing he's 20 he turns 22 at the end
of this month
and then Mackenzie she'll be
17. she lives with my sister up north
and then my youngest
um
she chose after my mother passed away
she chose to live with her friends
family
instead of my brother who was trying to
adopt her
and she's turning 15 this year
all this month all the kids are this
month
who raised your older kids
my ex-husband my ex-husband's Aunt
raised my son your sister and my sister
reads the the middle kid
what is your drug currently
um I smoke sweet and I smoke fat no
how do you support yourself
um my pan and a little and I sell drugs
looking back at your life now what would
you have done differently
honestly the only regret I have is
the passing of my my fiance so I guess I
would have tried to get us out off the
streets faster
your biggest fear now
um the biggest fear
is probably going back to the streets
that's me I don't want to [__] that I
couldn't I couldn't handle anymore
I got spoiled now that I'm indoors I
couldn't go back to the streets ever
again
what was the roughest part of living on
the streets
my boyfriend's murder
we went through some [__] we were
together for five almost five years
and we had been through it together dude
look it was being in a relationship on
the streets for five years as like being
in a 25-year marriage in a house you you
go through some
really tough [__] being trying to
maintain a relationship on on the
streets
why do you think you're in this
situation
I'm a drug addiction no I know but
what's behind that
um
because it sounds like your childhood is
pretty good
I mean
my my dad was abusive but I mean other
than that like that but I mean that's
that is a big thing I I tend to forget
like how big of a deal that is
but I mean honestly it did make me a
stronger person I wouldn't I wouldn't
change my childhood for anything do you
think maybe this is more of a something
you inherited from your biological dad
probably
for sure you just got a romaniac for
what I hear
you didn't you never knew him no
do you think this time on the streets
has changed you
it's made me more aware of my
surroundings I was kind of naive to that
before I became homeless when I moved
out to LA I was a stripper and I was
um eventually got into Club promoting
and I was hanging out with a pretty
high-end crowd and
selling Coke and stuff like that and I I
was just kind of
like that got you know got airheaded and
then when I got on the streets and then
you know I had to deal with gang
politics and [__] like that it became a
lot more real
and it's a very scary place to be
your siblings are doing better
um yeah my brother my brother is
actually just kind of um
coasting the country right now on the
God came into some money and it's just
going through divorce so he's taken off
and driving around in an RV got caught
up in drugs no no and my sister my older
sister doesn't either but I don't speak
to her
good
what emotions do you go through
most
um
hard one I
since Kevin's death I've just been
really [__] if I'm not loaded I'm I
am hysterically crying in my apartment
by myself
what's your favorite memory
yeah that's a tough one
um probably
all the times that I like woke up with
Kevin
and or Louise talking about an Elysian
Park I don't know if I can nowhere
and when we'd be like sleeping out under
the stars and [__]
those are very
does missing out on raising your kids
impact you as well
I'm thinking that's what started my drug
use
actually was losing my my first kid
having to give up custody of him was
really rough for me I couldn't handle it
and the only thing that kept me going
all those years before he turned 18 was
the thought that he would come find me
when he turned 18 because he would
remember me and stuff
but that didn't happen
and so that really that [__] me a bad
do you have friends out here good
friends no no
the friends nonetheless
there's really Street acquaintances yeah
all the people from my life in Hollywood
from when I was promoting and stuff I
don't I don't talk to them anymore I
actually with panhandling once and my
boss and his brother who was a DJ at one
of the clubs I worked at drove up and
gave me a dollar and they didn't even
recognize me and I [__] freaked out I
ran
I ran I just sat in the bathroom and I
cried I was like oh my God that was so
[__] mortifying I couldn't I couldn't
even believe that they didn't recognize
me
is it humiliating living this life
sometimes
oh yeah definitely
having people like
they told us one time we were all
hanging out at the post office and Echo
Park and um
they usually asked
for us to leave in the morning and take
off and they're like can you guys get
out of here so we can hose down the
steps
I was like wow really you're gonna say
that type of [__] like come on
oh like
that's just disrespectful on a whole
another level you don't say things like
that to people
how big a part is your
your self-worth the things you believe
about yourself how big a factor is that
in all of this
I mean I
I'm
it's pretty it's a very big deal to me
how people see me
and I strive to make sure that people
know I'm not
the stereotypical homeless person like I
don't steal from people I don't do that
type of [__]
it's just like that's beneath me I'm
I'm an energy I'm educated I shouldn't
even be shouldn't have ever been on the
street you know plug-in time to time
times are rough though and it happens
but I don't want people to think that
I'm just some ignorant dumb
drug user you know
what do you think the general public
doesn't understand about
drug addiction
that can happen to everybody
some people think that they're above it
but all it takes is a back injury you
know getting pills from your doctor
and liking the way they feel a little
too much you know that's all it takes
lucky what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
go with your gut feeling when you think
something's bad don't try to rationalize
it and make it so it's okay
because that could be what kills you
all right lucky thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
the best luck out here thank you